[Music]
on this Thursday night parliament's push
for a public inquiry into foreign
interference I declared the motion
carried fresh demands for a probe after
an MP at the center of Chinese influence
allegations quits the liberal caucus my
presence there may be seen by some as a
conflict of Duty the American president
comes to Canada what to expect from Joe
Biden's first official visit to Ottawa
and the Border deal reportedly already
on the table plus Tick Tock CEO pushes
back against calls to ban his company if
this committee gets its way tick tock's
time is up what he said during five
hours of testimony in the U.S
[Music]
thanks for joining us there are more
developments tonight in the story Global
News broke about allegations against a
Toronto MP Han dong resigned from the
liberal caucus last night after our
story aired he now sits as an
independent MP and today he voted in
favor of a public inquiry into foreign
interference National Security sources
tell Global News dong advised a Chinese
Diplomat in 2021 to delay the release of
the Canadians Michael spavor and Michael
kovrig from a Chinese jail while
announcing his departure from the
liberal caucus last night dong denied
that
media reports today quoted unverified
and Anonymous sources have attacked my
reputation and calling to questions my
loyalty to Canada
let me be clear
what has been reported
is false
and I will defend myself against these
absolutely untrue claims
it has only added to the demands for
answers about what the government knew
when Mackenzie gray has our top story
tonight
is in favor of the motion will please
rise it's the latest attempt from the
opposition to pressure the Liberals on
foreign interference
the NDP conservatives and block all
supported a non-binding motion calling
for a public inquiry the Liberals voted
against it there are communities that
are at risk of being stigmatized and the
only way for us to address all the
seriousness of this get to the bottom of
it and propose real solutions is with
the public inquiry newly minted
independent MP Han dong voted in favor
of a public inquiry after he announced
last night he was leaving the liberal
caucus sitting the government caucus is
a privilege
and my presence there may be seen by
some as a conflict of Duty dogs moved to
sit as an independent comes after global
news reported that in February 2021 dong
had a conversation with the Chinese
Consul General in Toronto where he
allegedly said Beijing should hold off
on immediately releasing Michael kovrig
and Michael spavor because it would be
politically beneficial for the
conservative party according to two
independent National Security sources
dong amenity spoke with the top Diplomat
but said he advocated for the two
Michael's release I want to assure Mr
Michael sparbert and Mr Michael covert
and their families that I did nothing
to cause them any harm at the end of his
speech Don got emotional thanking his
family to my wife Sophie and my kids
I love you
I thank you for all the support and love
you give me
the truth will protect us our honor and
our family will get through this
together
thank you speaker what do you make about
uh cabinet ministers supported Dong's
decision I think given the seriousness
of the allegations uh you made the right
decision he claims that that is false
and we'll we'll give him a chance to
prove it the prime minister's office
said it was not aware of the discussion
when it happened in February 2021 the
pmo said it learned about it from dong
but only after global news reached out
for comment on the story oral questions
but in question period the foreign
affairs minister would not say when the
Prime Minister learned about the dawn
conversation when did the Prime Minister
become aware of these allegations
bringing back the two Michaels Michael
kovrick and Michael spaver was the
outmost priority of this government one
person we haven't heard from Justin
Trudeau he's preparing for the Joe Biden
visit but Donna he's expected to take
questions from reporters tomorrow where
he'll likely be asked about the dong
allegations okay Mackenzie gray and
Ottawa the American President Joe Biden
is in Ottawa he arrived tonight for a
working visit with prime minister Justin
Trudeau this is Biden and his wife
Jill's first visit to Canada since Biden
was elected president it's the first
visit to Ottawa by a U.S president since
former president Barack Obama was here
in 2016. David Aiken is at the Ottawa
airport where the president arrived
earlier tonight David these meetings
more than symbolic they actually want to
get stuff done what's on the agenda
they do and there's lots on the agenda
Don I mean China Ukraine the climate
crisis the opioid crisis electric
vehicle manufacturing International
Trade lots of stuff but let me focus on
two important headlines we're going to
talk about over the next you know 20
hours or so first immigration Canada's
got a problem with what's called
irregular immigration some call it
illegal immigration this is a situation
where thousands of people are walking
into Canada from the United States
mostly at roxham Road in Quebec but on
Emerson Manitoba and elsewhere these
people come here claim Refugee status
and Canada cannot turn them away or else
Canada will be breaking treaty
obligations with the U.S Canada and the
U.S have been trying to work this out
and I can tell you government officials
Canadian government officials telling me
tonight there is a solution on the table
to stop the rocks and Road situation and
illegal migration the two leaders have
to sign off on it still some uh find
points to work out but we expect that
headline tomorrow some good news for
those who want to see more regular
migration now the other big issue Haiti
both leaders are horrified of what
they're seeing in Haiti it's a failed
State Lawless gangs roaming the streets
of course Canada has a special
relationship with Haiti because of all
the Haitian immigrants in Montreal the
Haitian Community Montreal but what can
Canada do the U.S may ask Canada for
some military assets Canada's military
right now overstretched we've got a big
commitment to Western Europe to help
defend Western Europe against Russian
invasion so we'll look for that those
headlines Haiti immigration and then as
I said a whole basket of other topics
the two leaders are going to talk about
okay and David President Biden is
staying in Ottawa overnight with his
wife Jill and into tomorrow what's he
going to be doing
well actually he's before he gets uh
beds down tonight uh he's been hosted by
the Trudeau's he and Jill Biden the
first lady uh is here and Sophie
Gregoire Trudeau and Justin Trudeau are
hosting them at their official residence
Rito Cottage here in the nation's
capital uh the first thing the bidens
did when they got here in Ottawa as soon
as they got off Air Force One right
behind me they met with governor general
Mary Simon that lasted a few minutes
um and uh the big meat of the program is
going to be tomorrow President Biden
will meet with Trudeau in a one-on-one
meet with Trudeau's cabinet and then
he's going to speak to Parliament he'll
give an address to Parliament just as
Obama did in 2016 we'll want to watch
that then they'll take a couple of
questions from reporters after that a
big Gala dinner for the bidens at the
aviation museum here in Ottawa and then
that's it the bidens come back here hop
on the world's most famous plane and
they will be back in their homes in
Wilmington Delaware tomorrow night David
Aiken in Ottawa thanks
as David talked about migrants entering
Canada from the U.S at uncontrolled
border crossings is a big issue
especially at rockson Road in Quebec The
Province says it no longer has the
resources to handle all the people Vara
Nasser went there to find out what's
happening
this small country road doesn't look
like much but it's been a big source of
tension half of rocks and Road sits in
New York state the other in Quebec last
year nearly 40 000 migrants crossed here
in search of a better life
with suitcases or in Williams case a
single gym bag where you come from
his family is in Montreal which is where
he's heading
William left his home in Haiti for
Brazil where he says he was able to get
a Visa then to the U.S Mexico border
where he walked into Texas and took a
bus to New York City where officials
have been buying Asylum Seekers bus
tickets North to Plattsburgh the last
stop before Canada
that's where cab drivers like Tom come
in completing the last half-hour leg to
the Border they're nervous they're
scared
we try to tell them that is
safe at the border the same scene plays
out over and over
here
the rest is temporary they will meet
with an immigration official and then
they can ask for Asylum this is
something they couldn't do at a legal
border crossing there's one about eight
kilometers away and that's what some
Advocates hope a new deal will address
if you actually allowed people to cross
at official ports of Entry
it would be possible for more people to
cross so you would think that would be
in the Americans interest I think the
United States and Canada really need to
look at the scale of the problem the
number of refugees coming up the issue
was not roxham road if you displace the
problem a few miles down the road you
will have the same problem somewhere
else when William arrives at the border
he listens to the same line crosses and
says he will apply for work
he says he was a taxi driver and
forklift operator back home to kleska
Canada I asked him if he's excited or
scared
scared of what he asks me
80 was difficult there was a lot of
violence after years of driving the
desperate Tom says it's what he learned
about their Journeys just getting here
that will stay with him knowing what
they went through some of these uh
Americans ought to try that foreign
Aster Global News roxham Road New York
the bodies of two more people were found
last night in the rubble of an apartment
building the burned down in Old Montreal
the number of bodies recovered so far is
four
the responders from all organizations on
the ground remain highly motivated and
determined to accomplish their mission
because what drives us
is to alleviate the anguish and the pain
of the families
three people are still missing officials
say there could be more and a second
crane was used today to help search the
rubble is Tick Tock a threat to National
Security coming up what its CEO told a
U.S congressional committee as it
contemplates a ban
the CEO of tick tock spent five hours
today being grilled about the video
sharing app it is wildly popular it has
more than 150 million monthly users just
in the U.S its CEO insists the app is
not a threat to National Security but
the Biden Administration is threatening
to ban it Jackson prosco on the 10th
Tick-Tock hearing
rarely has a social media company been
grilled like this Tick Tock is a weapon
by the Chinese Communist party to spy on
you manipulate what you see and exploit
for future Generations Tick Tock CEO
xiaoji Chu faced tough questions from
American lawmakers they were
increasingly ready to ban the platform
unless it's sold off by its Chinese
parent company bite dance has fight
dance spied on American citizens I don't
think the spying is the right way to
describe it
bite dance has previously admitted its
workers access the data of some U.S
Tick-Tock users there are broad fears
the app could be a Gateway for Chinese
spying or misinformation we do not
promote or remove content at the request
of the Chinese government just before
the hearing China said it would oppose a
forced sale of tick-tock under
questioning the company touted a plan to
wall off American user data instead the
bottom line is this
American data stored on American soil by
an American company overseen by American
Personnel the stakes have never been
higher for tick tock's one billion
Global users tick tock's creators were
called upon to wield their influence in
Washington if the app were shut down it
would be detrimental of course for me
and my business right because it's at
the core of our branding strategy but
Tick Tock can't escape the growing
technological cold war with China fear
could be its undoing in the United
States the Chinese Communist party is
spreading addictive and harmful videos
to Young Americans through its algorithm
the world's most popular app may be
operating on borrowed time unable to
overcome worry about its Deep Reach into
daily life
Jackson prosco Global News
persistent problem ahead what could
solve surgery backlogs in
[Music]
Canada the long wait list for surgery in
Canada that built up during the pandemic
are getting shorter but the backlogs
haven't cleared Catherine Ward reports
on the call for a new approach to
tackling them
we care about our patients we care about
each other the whole thing has been very
frustrating Anu Marlene knows what it's
like to wait her knee surgery was
canceled when her blood pressure
skyrocketed soon she'll be back on a
wait list hopefully it's not going to be
a long wait because
walking around with knee pain is it's
quite debilitating and frustrating and
painful the Canadian Institute for
health information has been tracking
surgery backlogs over the course of the
pandemic while more surgeries are now
being done the backlog is still well
above pre-pandemic levels we can see
that there's only been a couple of
occasions where the numbers of surgeries
completed have risen above what was done
in 2019. if we aren't able to sustain
219 levels and higher we won't be able
to catch up there is a lot of variation
for knee surgeries when looking at data
from 2022 in British Columbia 56 percent
of surgeries were performed within the
recommended time frame of about six
months that drops to 23 percent for
patients in Saskatchewan and Ontario
tops the list with 68 percent of people
getting the surgery within the desired
window Dr John Townley says the
operating rooms at Humber River Hospital
in Toronto are running at capacity they
have some of the shortest wait time the
vast majority of our cases are now Day
Surgery cases I.E after the surgery is
completed we do not have to admit the
patients to a surgical bed on the floor
they are discharged home experts say the
discrepancies are unacceptable we run
all our health Care Systems in silos we
need a more National approach
got because quality of life is on the
line these people are in pain they can't
work their families are falling apart
they're suffering from addiction because
of their pain Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
next a look at how presidential visits
have shaped U.S Canada relations
American presidents have been making
trips North to visit Canada for 100
years the first was in 1923 when
President Warren G Harding the 29th U.S
president visited Vancouver and the last
was five years ago when the 45th U.S
president Donald Trump was in Quebec
that was for a summit of G7 leaders Eric
Sorensen looks at how these visits have
shaped our relationship with our
neighbor
president speaking on Canadian soil in
1938 the Breakthrough in modern Canada
U.S relations began with Franklin
Roosevelt in the depths of the
depression he broke with America's
isolationism and high tariffs
[Music]
in the countries
permitting them to sell Goods to us
Roosevelt vacationed in Canada and with
Prime Minister Mackenzie King
established the foundation for relations
based on security and trade Franklin
Roosevelt he appreciated the Strategic
importance of Canada he cultivated
Mackenzie King who also fundamentally
understood that Canada's economy and
economic growth depended on having
privileged access to the United States
Market the relationship between prime
ministers and presidents have been
tested ever since dieffenbaker and
Eisenhower approved NORAD Air Defense in
this country but deep fell out with
Kennedy when he did not approve American
nuclear warheads here Pierre Trudeau did
not have a warm relationship with Ronald
Reagan yet Brian mulrooney was
criticized for being too friendly with
him
[Music]
credited with Reagan giving in on key
Provisions in the two Nations first free
trade agreement we would not have got it
and especially the key piece of dispute
settlement but for that relationship
between Brian Mulroney and Ronald Reagan
it is the largest bilateral trading
relationship in the world some
relationships have been warm others
Frosty as when Barack Obama turned down
Stephen Harper and the Keystone Pipeline
and the leader's Smiles belied intense
mistrust between Justin Trudeau and
Donald Trump over New American tariffs
it's kind of insulting
and I highlighted that it was not
helping Trudeau's relationship with
President Biden is very different they
share a genuine affection and common
goals the center of our conversations
will be about jobs and growth they also
share common challenges with China and
Russia and conservative opposition at
home dealing with Joe Biden is about as
easy as a guest yes he's a protectionist
but he will understand the importance of
Canada just the same way uh Franklin
Roosevelt like every prime minister
Justin Trudeau must persuade this
president that what's good for Canada is
also good for the United States Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
is global national for this Thursday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada is
Santa killawak Nunavut thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
foreign